[Music]
let's go to jill in cedar city utah
what's up jill
hi dr john i'm so honored to be speaking
with you i am more honored to be talking
to you what's up
i'm a little nervous um i appreciated
that last call bye to sing in a band so
i can relate to a lot of that thank you
you got it thank you so much so what's
up um my question is how do i show up
for my kids and my husband through this
transition phase that we're in and not
get exhausted
um so i guess you want a little back
story um i could just start throwing
answers at you the
probably be incredible but yes some more
contacts would be helpful
okay so i got married in november this
is my second marriage okay um we don't
live together thank you
we live 30 minutes apart
um
so half the time i'm home raising my
kids doing all that stuff why don't
y'all live together
because the housing market is still high
here we're just kind of sitting and
waiting
um
well it's also because i have
five kids and their whole lives are
right here and they have to go to school
here
and
he's got a ranch where he's at so we're
just not sure how to meet in the middle
but there really is nothing nothing
coming up
for us um
so
you get that you've put yourself in a
pretty tough position to be successful
right
yeah i'm working three jobs at home
to try and make ends meet where i'm at
and i do enjoy i do enjoy those things
is your husband
not like at some point he has to decide
you all have to decide
are we gonna move these five kids to the
ranch
and we're gonna do this life thing
together
or he's gonna
get somebody to take care of his ranch
and he's going to move into your place
y'all's place
or
you're going to sell both things and
move to texas i don't know i don't care
what you all are doing
but you got married and then you just
kept living each other's independent
lives i guess you'll get together for
weekend hookups or whatever but like
this isn't a marriage you know what i
mean no yeah it doesn't feel like a
marriage no well i mean it's it just set
out of the gate without being a marriage
y'all wouldn't got a certificate and had
a ceremony but like y'all aren't married
like his money is your money and your
money is his money and his kids are your
kids i mean y'all learn this thing
together
right yes that's how it feels
it is
so what's the what's the hold up um i
did offer to move there and travel with
my kids back and forth
but he wanted to keep one of his
bedrooms for his children for his son to
come home when he wanted to come home
and house is really small i'm in a
rental
he owns his place
jail joe joe joe jill jill
i
i'm assuming that no one's told you what
i'm about to tell you and you know if
you've listened to this show more than
once that i will never lie to you okay
um
but this isn't gonna work
you don't marry somebody and let them
rent a house in another city
so that you can have an extra spare room
for your kids whenever they show up what
a mess
yeah the other thing that's making this
really hard is he has um anxiety and
depression that and i just that that i'm
trying to show up for him that is all i
could care less about that right now
that isn't the other problem
you all have created a completely
disconnected existence from one another
and you're calling each other husband
and wife you are no more married than me
and i was gonna say me and kelly but me
and kelly are more married than y'all
two are
right she's like within 10 feet of me i
see her every single day for hours on
end god help us all and i'm just kidding
she's but you know see what i'm saying
just your language
he doesn't want me in his house it's
y'all's house
did you send a prenup that
that you don't that the ranch you have
nothing to do with ranch
um i'm not on
no and i'm not on any of the financial
things i know but you're his wife
if he died today you're the wife it goes
to you
yeah it goes to his ex-wife his life
insurance
what
um that was in his divorce
that until his last child support
payment
his life insurance goes to that place
and
i think the state would take his his
home and land and stuff at this point so
i don't we talked about it several times
he hasn't really given me an answer
okay okay listen
i am very
lazy
i'm real big on somebody called earlier
in this show and asked me you know their
husband had cheated on him a couple of
times and asked me and i
my answer to them was what do you think
so here's what i'm telling you i'm not
telling you what do you think
i'm telling you you deserve more than
this
you all deserve more than this
and y'all are playing married
in a tragic way your kids are getting a
picture of this is what marriage looks
like
this is how a man takes care of his life
she works three jobs and rents a house
in another city because i want to keep
an empty bedroom
i mean it's non the whole thing is
insane right
and i don't know what this dude's trying
to pull off but
um
i have a real real direct heart wait
what happens if he dies
i guess you go on renting a house
working three jobs right you're living a
life
you are living the life that we i tell
people to get life insurance to avoid
you know what i mean
how long have you all been married in
november
yeah
so here's if i'm you
i'm all gonna tell you if i'm you
i would say hey we need that we need to
talk
and i'll even drive out to your ranch
and by the way i'd start changing that
language real quick to our ranch
hours
to our rental home
to our kids
this you and my stuff
your marriage will never it will never
work because it's our stuff and my stuff
and your stuff
this is
ours
we're in this thing together
that fine he's got a life insurance
policy for his ex-wife through some
decree fine he's gonna have to get one
on you
oh i started that process myself
no he's got to participate
not participate he's got to lead the
effort
okay to love his new wife enough to take
care of her if he dies
so that's a small price to pay
you'll have to have a three-month plan
to unify your families
and at some point you may have to look
at him and say is this ranch more
important your marriage to me because if
it is i need to know
because then i got to make other plans
if you're keeping this ranch up
and it might be i mean it might be an
incredible ranch i'm all about ranches
i'm from texas i love me a good ranch i
would love to have one one day
um it will never be more important than
my wife
i'm never gonna i can't even wrap my
head around my wife living 45 minutes
away
with five kids renting a house i mean
just sounds preposterous you know what
i'm saying and here's what happens this
stuff happens step by step quietly and
quietly and you start to think this is
normal
and so hear me say joe you're not crazy
this is nuts
do you feel isolated out on an island by
yourself
yeah
yeah i feel you should cause you are
and i here's what i hate i hate that
this might end up in a really messy
situation
i do
i hate you having to sit down and say do
you love this ranch more than me
because i can't do marriage we're just
gonna be married and just live in other
towns indefinitely
while your kids do whatever and my five
kids like that's just how it's gonna
work man you gotta have a plan to come
together
and he and he might say no
okay so be ready for the
but you all need to get in a room and
you need to write down really quick what
you need you need life insurance you
need to live with your husband you need
to have your husband involved in your
five kids lives you don't need to come
up with a plan for working with exes you
all need to dig all that go through all
that stuff
and not just hook up on weekends
is that fair is that fair
yeah that's fair i feel like i'm getting
on to you but i'm not trying to get on
to i'm just trying to i'm trying to like
just shake the snow globe a little bit
and let you see how bonkers this is
yeah it still feels bonkers okay because
it is so if nothing if nothing else you
called uh yahoo with a podcast and a
youtube show to tell you that yes you
are correct this is bonkers
this is this is bonkers now as a part of
healing
your husband may have to deal with his
anxiety in his depression 100
that's done with connection not hiding
on a range
he may have to deal with his anxiety and
depression that's something he's got to
decide as as a person
living in the world i want to heal from
this this is not something that you can
just quote unquote manage or have to
quote unquote deal with that's not how
he's going to heal
okay he's got to decide i want to be a
part of this and then you can be a part
of his healing plan but it's going to
have to be something he decides he wants
to heal from
so when he's around my kids he's he's
very
impatient
i don't want to put him down because he
plays with him and he's super sweet
but he gets really impatient really
quickly and very critical
yes yes yes
his kids were kind of taken from him and
don't have much to do with them and so i
think it triggers him to be around my
kids so here's the deal i'm not letting
anybody
who is going to be triggered around my
children around my children
and i realize this puts you in a strange
pickle because you decided to marry this
guy
but i'm not putting somebody around my
kids it's not safe to be around my kids
even if it's my new uh new husband
and so we're gonna have a conversation
you and him about here's what it looks
like when you're with our kids you're
patient and you're kind and you're
gentle
and you're fun
and we will slowly lean into
accountability as we blend these
families together
but i'll take the chief
the lion's share of the discipline as we
transition this thing and slowly move it
as the kids come to trust you and love
you and that only comes through presence
and connectivity
day in day out relationship relationship
relationship
it's not this random dude who shows up
every week to hook up with their mom and
then goes back to his ranch
man what a mess
my heart's broken for you jill i'm sorry
um there's only hard conversations ahead
my hope is that you sit down and say you
have a list of your needs written out
i got to be safe i've got to be with you
i've got to live in the same house as
you with these five kids i've got to
have these things this is what a
marriage is ours
i've got to be on the deed to the house
that we're going to share together in
case you die so i have a place to live
so they don't ship it all off to your
ex-wife i'm your new wife
i'm first
i'm first i'm first i'm first cause i'm
your wife and we're gonna start there
and my hope is he goes oh thank god
will you walk with me as we untangle all
this yes i will i'm all in so i married
you
but you gotta know this conversation is
gonna be a risk
because you might say i'm not doing all
that
it's too much of a mess let's come back
in a year and whatever and i would tell
them
well i'm not going to tell you that
i'll tell you i wouldn't wait a year
that's what i'm telling you
because i married you a year ago
i'm so sorry jill